[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about every starter
Pokemon in the Kanto Johto and Hoenn
regions including their strengths
weaknesses special abilities basic stats
and so on I initially wanted to cover
all seven regions in this one video but
then I realized that if I did that the
video would be like 40 minutes long so I
decided to split the video up into two
parts
if you end up enjoying this video and
you want to see part 2 be sure to leave
a like and if we get over 1000 likes
then I will get to work on part two
right away and of course if you are new
to the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
can be notified when the new video comes
out before we get started I want to give
a quick shout out to my good friend NOx
Taku who just released a video on his
channel with the honest descriptions for
every starter Pokemon NOx has a great
sense of humor and he is pretty much the
Grand Master of anime sarcasm his honest
descriptions video is hilarious so be
sure to check it out after you watch
this link in the description and
starting things off with the Kanto
region all the way back in Gen 1
Charmander is the fire type starter
Pokemon in the Kanto region it resembles
a small orange dinosaur it walks on two
feet and it has a long tail a flame
burns on the tip of each charmander's
tail and the strength of the flame can
actually tell us how the Charmander is
feeling if the Charmander is angry the
flame will be intense and when it is
happy the flame will waver playfully in
battle when a Charmander is strong the
flame will also be strong and bright but
if the Charmander is weak or out of
energy the flame will also be weak it is
said that if the flame on a Charmander
stale is ever extinguished the Pokemon
would die in the wild charmander's are
found in warmer mountain areas such as
near volcanoes and in the classic game
Pokemon snap you can take pictures of
wild pack so Charmander in the volcano
area a Charmander evolves into a
Charmeleon at level 16 and into a
Charizard at level 36 when he becomes a
Charizard the Pokemon grows wings and is
able to fly and in this form he looks a
lot like a fire-breathing dragon
Charmander is weak against water ground
and rock-type pokémon but he is strong
against the bog and grass types which is
why he is one of the most popular
starters in the first generation since a
lot of the wild Pokemon that a player
encounters at the beginning are bog and
grass types in the first generation
games a Charmander appear to have spikes
on its back but these spikes were
removed in the later generations
charmander's Japanese name is he toka
gay next up is squirtle the water type
starter Pokemon in Kanto squirtle looks
like a blue turtle
but unlike a turtle it often walks on
two legs rather than four squirtle is an
expert in using water type moves as you
might expect but it is also very apt in
using normal type physical attacks like
skull bash squirtle possesses a hard
shell that it can use for protection and
potentially as a weapon in battle as a
water type squirtle is weak against
electric and grass type Pokemon but
strong against other types such as fire
in the wild squirtle can be found near
bodies of water it evolves into
Wartortle at level 16 and into Blastoise
at level 36
Blastoise was always my personal
favorite final evolution out of all the
first generation starters because he
looks like a walking turtle tank and I
always thought that that was extremely
cool squirtles japanese name is NE
gummit and then we have Bulbasaur the
grass type starter Pokemon in Kanto
although Bulbasaur is also a poison type
Pokemon at the same time Bulbasaur is a
green reptile-like creature that walks
on four legs and has a large bulb on its
back which is where the name Bulbasaur
comes from the bulb on its back allows
Bulbasaur to draw energy from the Sun
just like plants do through
photosynthesis
Bulbasaur can extend long and powerful
vines from the bulb on its back and use
them as both a weapon and a tool for
accomplishing various tasks when it
comes time for a Bulbasaur to evolve its
body will light up in a glory
blue color and it evolves into Ivysaur
at level 16 and into Venusaur at level
32 penis or still looks a lot like
bulbasaur except that it is bigger and a
bulb on its back sprouts into a large
red flower Bulbasaur is weak against
certain types of Pokemon like fire and
flying but he is strong against other
types like water Bulbasaur has the
highest base stat total out of all the
starters with 318 compared to squirrels
314 and charmander's 309 although he is
believed to be the least popular out of
the three primary starters many have
argued that Bulbasaur is statistically
the best choice out of the three I will
leave a link to a video that argues that
exact point in the description below
Bulbasaur's japanese name is Fushigi
denis and that's it for the Kanto region
starters now moving on to Johto
wait I feel like I'm forgetting
something yes of course in the Kanto
region we also have Pikachu Pikachu is
an electric-type pokémon that is the
only available starter in pokemon yellow
Pikachu is essentially a yellow electric
Mouse who can alternate between walking
on two feet and on all fours it stores
electricity in the pouches inside its
cheeks as a way for the player to mirror
the journey that Ash goes on in the
first season of the anime pokemon yellow
makes Pikachu your only available
starter and then it gives you a chance
to catch the other three starters
through special events that are not
available in the previous games normally
a Pikachu will evolve into right you
through the use of a thunder stone but
just like Ash's Pikachu your starter in
pokemon yellow will refuse to evolve so
the only way to evolve it is to trade it
first
Pichu was introduced in generation 2 as
a pre evolution of Pikachu a Pichu can
be involved into a Pikachu if you level
him up with high friendship also known
as happiness at first Pikachu has the
lowest total base stats out of the four
Kanto starters at 300 this number
remains the same throughout generations
1 to 5 but then with generation 6 and
onward Pikachu's total base Tatsu
up to 320 to this day Pikachu is the
most recognizable mascot for the Pokemon
franchise and its Japanese name is also
Pikachu and now on to Johto CENTAC will
is the fire-type starter pokemon and
Johto the region that we discover in
generation 2 with games that include
pokemon gold silver crystal HeartGold
and SoulSilver cyndaquil appears to be
based at least in part on a real-world
animal known as the ochita which lives
in the regions of New Guinea and
Australia
the flames on cyndaquil 'he's back a
reminiscent of the spines on the backhoe
and a kid 'no like with Charmander the
flames on cyndaquil 'he's back become
stronger if it gets angry pokemon
crystal was actually the first pokemon
game that I played and my starter
Pokemon was cyndaquil cyndaquil evolved
into pre lava at level 14 and into
Typhlosion at level 36 i remember that
by the end of the game Typhlosion and
Tyranitar were the two pokemon on my
team that I liked the most cynical z'
base stats total is 309 he is weak
against water ground and rock types but
strong against other types like bug
grass and steel cyndaquil Japanese name
is he no era she and many believe that
he is the best overall starter choice
for generation 2 next up is Totodile
Totodile is the water type starter
Pokemon in the johto region
Totodile is essentially a small
crocodile that walks on two feet and
this pokemon is known for its sharp
teeth and large powerful jaw found near
bodies of water
Totodile has a nasty habit of biting
anything and everything it comes across
so even its trainer has to be careful
Totodile is the heaviest and tallest out
of all the water type starters and its
name appears to be a combination of the
words taught as in small child or
toddler and crocodiles so he is
basically a baby crocodile Totodile
evolves into Kraken ah at level 18 and
into Feraligatr at level 30
Totodile is weak to grass and
electric-type pokémon but strong against
fire steel and ice types it's total base
stats are 314 so 5 higher than cyndaquil
and it's Japanese name
is one in O club and finally we have
chikorita the grass type starter of the
johto region chikorita is a small green
creature that walks on 4 legs and has a
leaf growing out of the top of its head
like Bulbasaur chikorita also has the
ability to use vines that come in handy
as either tools or weapons and
unsurprisingly in the wild Chikorita is
liked to hang out in grassy areas
chikorita evolves into bayleaf at level
16 and into Meganium at level 32 it has
a base stats total of 318 which is
higher than both cyndaquil and Totodile
nonetheless Chikorita has quite a few
weaknesses including fire poison ice bug
and flying-type pokémon it is strong
against water electric and ground types
as well as other grass type Pokemon
Chikorita was initially designed with a
yellow body but this was later changed
to green it's Japanese name is also
Chikorita and in fact Chiquita's
evolutions bay leaf and Meganium also
have the same names in English and
Japanese and now on to the Hoenn region
Torchic is the fire type starter pokémon
in the Hoenn region Torchic is basically
the fried chicken Pokemon since Torchic
is a baby chicken that keeps an internal
flame somewhere inside its stomach
Torchic is capable of using fire type
attacks that can reach temperatures of
up to 1,000 degrees Celsius
rather than mountains or volcanoes
Torchic is a fire-type Pokemon that
tends to inhabit grassy areas in the
wild torchic's name is a combination of
the words torch and chick meaning baby
chicken it evolves into a Combusken at
level 16 and into Blaziken at level 36
tor tricks japanese name is accommo and
its base stats total is 310 it is weak
against water ground and rock types but
strong against grass I steel plug fairy
and other fire type Pokemon Torchic
weighs the least out of all the fire
type starter Pokemon next up is Mudkip
the water type starter pokémon in the
Hoenn region Mudkip is amphibious
meaning that it can live on both land
and water and in the wild it can be
found in swamps and martial
for that reason it is known as the mud
fish pokémon Mudkip can actually use the
fin on its head to sense changes in
water and air currents giving it a
strong sense of spatial awareness Mudkip
has a base that's total of 310 just like
Torchic it is weak against electric and
grass type Pokemon which makes sense for
a water type and it is strong against
fire steel and ice Mudkip evolves into
Marshtomp at level 16 and Swampert at
level 36 its english name Mudkip is
essentially a combination of the words
mud and skip and it's Japanese name is
Mizumoto there is actually an amphibious
fish in the real world known as the
mudskipper and this animal was likely
the inspiration for Mudkip and the grass
type starter in the Hoenn region is
Treecko Treecko is essentially a green
lizard who walks on two feet and as he
is the wood gecko pokémon we know that
he was inspired by the real-life gecko
like many lizards Treecko is an
extremely skilled climber and in the
wild Treecko can be found in large
forests and tall trees treecko's long
tail allows it to sense environmental
factors like humidity enabling it to
predict the weather for the next day
just like the other two Hoenn starters
treecko's base stats total is 310 he
evolves into Grovyle at level 16 and
Sceptile at level 36 Treecko is weak to
quite a few Pokemon types including fire
flying poison bug and ice he is strong
against water Electric ground and other
grass types treecko's English name is a
combination of the words tree and gecko
it's Japanese name is Komori overall all
three starter pokémon in the Hoenn
region are pretty well balanced so your
best choice will ultimately depend on
your playing style and that is it for
this video every starter Pokemon in the
Kanto Johto and Hoenn region explained
don't forget to leave a like if you want
to see part two where I will cover all
the starter Pokemon in sin oh you know
vocalist and a Lola if you are new to
the channel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell and you
can also check us out on Twitter and
Instagram where we post new anime
content
every day our handle is at Anime uproar
be sure to check out NOx tacos video on
the honest descriptions for every
starter Pokemon link in the description
as always thank you so much for watching
and until next time see our space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]